[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BIRDS CHIRPING]
The Kaibab Plateau is home
to one of the last ponderosa
pine forests in the southwest.
It's a unique habitat, protected
by Grand Canyon National Park,
and a spectacle to behold.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Less than 5% of the 6 million
annual visitors to the park
make it beyond the rim.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
For most, a trip to
a scenic overlook
is enough to get a taste of
the beauty in this magic place.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
But for those with a
sense of adventure,
traveling into the heart of the
park can be quite the thrill.
[WATER RUSHING]
[SPLASHING]
A Grand Canyon rafting trip is
the adventure of a lifetime.
It can take two weeks to
raft its entire length.
Entrusting their
fate to the river,
paddlers navigate their
way through at least
80 big water rapids, including
the infamous Lava Falls.
[WATER RUSHING]
The waters of the Colorado
are a rafters mecca--
but it's best not to fall in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The Grand Canyon
Pink Rattlesnake--
only found in this
region, it's perfectly
adapted to canyon life.
[TONGUE FLICKING]
While the river is a
barrier to some, for him,
it's an opportunity.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Swimming gives him
the freedom to search
for new hunting grounds.
His ability to scour
more of the park
gives Grand Canyon its own
natural form of rodent control.
Spring is a common season
to spot rattlesnakes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]